we got to go see Travis Scott as well oh
that's sick that was an amazing show I
was it was it's the
best
rap arena show I've
seen yeah and I don't know the
songs I know Butterfly Effect I know fi
yeah it's pretty much it yeah um funny I
don't know the songs if I knew the songs
it'd be even crazier but I asked him
afterwards and I was like yo man usually
rap sucks live like what like why the
show was really good like I was like it
was really it was an engaging fun show
and he goes yeah he goes I think the
problem is a lot
of artists don't make music for the live
show he go I'm making music for the live
show so it is for this environment it is
for this Arena it's for everybody to
rage to that's a term that he uses it's
for us all to to go crazy and that's why
it resonates when you're at the show
some people make amazing music for you
to drive to and now you at the show and
it's like oh this is better when I'm
sitting down in my car and I'm just
cooling and I thought it was like a
really interesting distinction yeah like
the songs that we love are dependent on
an environment sometimes yeah and we
love them for that environment yeah yeah
and uh for him to recognize that I was
like oh yeah I saw him at wilding out it
like 2016 or something I'd never seen
anything as I'm I'm there I I was
leaving cuz I was like I'm not filming
the episode I'm just going to go but as
I'm leaving I hear him he's starting to
warm up he's just like singing in the
mic and then the music starts playing
and I'm just sticking around a little
bit like this is you can feel an energy
in the room it's crazy and I remember
the [__] whole thing the venue is
shaking this is a comedy show taping and
he's got the venue literally shaking oh
bro everybody had their shirt off yeah
it was awesome it's crazy there all
these white dudes with their shirt off
if he said jump off the balcony i i
10 500 would have done it probably like
I and I I literally I told him that I
was like dude that that is like a
dangerous amount of power right there
like like if he said jump off the
balcony I 100% promise he knows yeah I
know the yeah but no it's like he did
something at the end that I thought was
really cool it was uh you know the song
fiend that he has fiend with him and
cardi right they're feing for more
whatever that is and then he the Beat
Drops and she goes Fe Fe so he plays
it while he looks around the audience
four interesting couples or people and
then he kind of points them out and he
goes I know that person right there how
old are you and the kid's like I'm 14
years old or something like that and
then this was actually a funny moment he
goes and you're here by yourself he goes
yeah I'm here by yourself he goes 14
years old here by yourself I love that
and we were like wait what and then and
then he goes he goes yeah I think this
kid right here he feeding for more and
then it drops and the kid's going crazy
and he does that with interesting groups
it was a dad and his son his son is 12
his dad is 50 he goes we got a
50-year-old here I know he's feeding for
more and the kid and the dad are going
and they're on the Jumbotron as well so
small he made the whole place feel so
small so it's super connectivity and
also a moment MH like for that person I
remember I saw Jay do this back in the
day points out people are wearing and he
kind of like it's almost like a roast
but he's acknowledging them like I seen
this girl going for you in the blouse
you're going crazy and you have a moment
with Jay what I like about this is you
have a moment with your favorite
musician and then the whole crowd sings
for your moment yeah that's dope so it's
like you you get to be Travis for a
second wow and it's like and he played
the same song maybe eight times or
something at the end MH and and it
wasn't it wasn't like okay I'm over this
as long as the people he picked out were
interesting or the story was interesting
for some reason I'm like okay I I want
to see this go down the 50-year-old dad
and the 12-year-old kid it was the kid
was so excited yeah can't even imagine
and every person had their own little
moment it was so cool and it was just
like he really curates the live show and
I think this is something that like a
lot of rappers [__] up is they don't try
to make the live show which is the thing
that they make the most [__] money at
as dynamic as it can be and lean into
the type of music they're making and
create that experience that those people
need to have yeah cuz you see some it's
like oh my God this is the most boring
[__] show I've ever seen in my life
yeah yeah but he's always been one of
those artists that he puts so much
effort into the live show like since the
beginning of his career he's always been
known like yo his live show is nothing
and he he's cool like he's objectively
cool but he doesn't try to make the
whole experience too cool which I
actually really appreciate like there's
moments where he's pulling people and
putting them on like these moving like
uh like risers that are like floating
throughout the arena and he's not just
like only picking like bad [__] to
bring up he's like yo that guy in the
crutches that's a real fan shirt off
with crutches get up here and he brings
a dude with crutches up on the thing and
then like there's a dude with his shirt
out he's got like he's in his underwear
and instead of him being like yo that
sus he's like yo that guy I need more of
that that guy's feing for more and like
boom goes in what's crazy is that was a
stadium show in an arena cuz he did that
same show at Sofi in LA with 70,000
people so when you're in the arena and
he covers the entire floor in this
like Temple is the set it looks like uh
what is
that Temple but it puts him close to
everyone in the arena put it this way so
let's say this thing right here is the
arena and this is the floor like this is
where the Knicks would play this is
where all the seats would be for like
Scotia Bank yeah almost that whole
section is his set that there's a little
trim that like people that have like the
floor access can go around but there's
only maybe a few hundred people on the
floor so most people are seated and he's
walking around the set and there's like
all these elevated components in the set
so he's kind of always in your Visual
and people can kind of follow him around
but um yeah it was just like it was
extreme attention and detail to the show
like not to compare it to to Taylor but
it felt like Taylor in that every part
of the show was really I don't want to
use the word choreographed but it was
thoughtful thoughtful yeah which is
important yeah incredibly important I
always love that but it sounds like an
expensive show though oh I it it must be
so [__] expensive to produce that
show for him like I mean we know we look
into these things
like mind-bogglingly I got to look up
the price for the tickets because just
to break even on a show like that yeah
and keep in mind you're limiting the
amount of people now you have no floor
that can be thousands of people on the
floor so I'm like is he making money
some floor little we lost Shifty to the
mosh pit oh yeah Shifty hit the mosh pit
that was shifty's first concert dude his
one of his favorite artists of all time
is Travis guy that's lit he go he gets
to meet him but also goes to his first
concert and like he hit the mosh it was
crazy the craziest thing production wise
is he was in Boston in that Arena 10
days before and the normal logic is you
would leave up all that stuff and do two
nights in a row so they have to set up
and break that down the reason that's
crazy is is
because the expense for a show a lot of
times is the staff to set it up and then
take it down so if you can stay in a
city for multiple days yeah you only
have to pay to set it up once set it up
and take it down twice is like super
expensive moving all the gear whatever
but uh but yeah it was it was just cool
it's cool to see people that are at the
highest level with that attention to
detail yeah like I I like that I I like
seeing successful people not being like
oops I guess oh here it is yeah I like
seeing someone go yeah we' thought about
every part of this these people pay a
lot of money to come out to the show and
they deserve to have this experience y
yeah it was awesome and it looks like
tickets aren't actually crazy if you get
them right right when they sell
obviously resale is probably while but
you can probably get nose beds it says
here for like 25 35 40 bucks and then at
the floor it's looks it looks like three
like 250 3 even that is not that CRA
just let everyone know most seats in an
arena are great so get your seats like
that was that's a bargain but no it was
go it was dope I mean just what a
[__] cool weekend and then the
picture y'all took was
funny oh yeah I didn't know like again I
don't know Travis that much so I don't
know that he always looks down in a pick
so he does his thing where like he
always looks down yeah right so we took
the pick and I'm
like you asked to say hi to
me what what is this so I didn't know
that that's his thing yeah but it's fine
that's his thing so you you don't look
you look cool you a little rat no no no
we're fine but it was one of those
things where I didn't get it at first
and I was like oh no this crazy bro like
how you going to disrespect me like that
like that's wild all right what would
little Enthusiast show your pose if you
knew he was going to do that pose I
would have acted more excited I like i'
lean in to him being the cool one and me
being like the nerd I wish I kind of
knew what it was but now then I somebody
sent me some pictures that he was doing
it with different people and I go okay
okay okay this is his thing but there
was a moment I was like this
[__] got
me about to step to him son I'm used to
that [__] cuz that's how black dudes
take pictures black dudes come up to you
ask you to take a picture and you look
like the one that asked like you'll look
at cuz I'll take the selfie and the
black dude will be it'll be like looking
off to the side
I'll be cheesed
up but it was fire the whole weekend was
amazing that sounds crazy yo shout out
Boston man thank y'all man that was that
was far